I don't know Samuel Leeds hey what's up
my name's Samuel Leeds I'm a property
investor and in this video I'm gonna be
addressing some of the controversies has
been picked up around the newspapers and
TV between myself and Lord Sugar
so here's the big question is it true
that I pretended to have met with Lord
Sugar and received a business advice or
an in touring session with him or was it
in fact a completely lie and really did
I just get a cheeky photograph with him
following a brief meet and greet which
is what he says so let me first just
give a little bit of background to this
I have always been an admirer of Lord
Sugar I love The Apprentice show I also
the fact that he's got such a massive
property portfolio and he's a TV star I
mean who wouldn't want to sit with Lord
Sugar and pick his brain for an hour or
so and have some business advice I
certainly did so much so that I paid
four thousand eight hundred pounds
for just one hour of his time where
myself Lord Sugar
and four other businesses sat around a
round table and we all discussed
business with Lord Sugar
he answered business questions gave
business advice that each person around
the room which lasted for just over one
hour it was a great session I took a
picture with him I posted it I said
great to have a mentoring session with
Lord Sugar in fact other people around
the table did the same thing because we
were number one I wanted to honor Lord
Sugar because if I've received help from
somebody whether that be a mentor
whether that be a friend I'm always
going to talk well of them I'm always
going to say that they've helped me in
the same way that hopefully if you've
received help from me and if you've
liked my videos maybe you see me as a
mentor then I would love hearing you
tell that and I'd love to be part of
your story there was a guy sat next to
me called Sam and Sam made the
newspapers and it said this person had
received business advice from Lord Sugar
the same business session the same
mentoring session whatever you want to
call it that I had had with Lord Sugar
however don't dawn Lord Sugar
made a video about me saying that he
didn't know who I was and he had never
given me business advice and that it was
not true it was a complete fantasy I
don't know
Samuel Leeds I met him briefly at a
conference a few years ago and he claims
that I have given him business advice
and mented him are pure fantasy and
completely untrue this was picked up by
channel 4 TV this went in the Sun
newspaper and to be quite honest I was a
little bit surprised to see it because I
had received business advice from Lord
Sugar I've got the payment slips four
thousand eight hundred pound proving
this I've got the email threat proving
that I booked a business roundtable
session with Lord Sugar through
seriously fun business Charlotte now
emailed me saying when it's not going to
be too structured we need to allow time
for people to ask questions relevant to
their business it was a business advice
session so I they gave this back to the
Sun newspaper the Sun
I didn't change their story a little bit
Thank You Sun newspaper Channel for
recently talked about it everyone's been
going crazy about it and since putting
the evidence out there while the Sun
newspaper people are now accusing me of
well it wasn't mentoring though listen
listen I'm sorry if I gave anybody the
wrong idea and actually like me and Lord
Sugar were like best buddies but that's
never what I said what I said is that
I've paid for mentoring from Lord Sugar
we had a session and a business advice
session together but why is it that me
and another person we had the same
business advice session the other person
called Sam made the newspapers and it
was headlined that he had a business
advice from Lord Sugar but me who'd had
the same business advice was in the
newspaper saying that I haven't had
business advice and that I'm a liar
by the way Lord Sugar if it never
happened maybe you could just refund me
the four thousand out in Japan and I'll
give that to charity if it was just a
meet and greet but anyway I don't know
about you but I think there's probably a
little bit of an agenda going on whether
me they were trying to make me look bad
and trying to discredit me but it
doesn't matter
everything that Lord Sugar taught me in
our business advice session that I paid
four thousand a hundred pounds for
everything they told me I have put
together into a training
and it's really good because he taught
me a lot and I paid 4,800 pounds for it
which I was happy with I would like to
offer you the same opportunity where you
can pay four thousand nine hundred
pounds and I'll pass on all the
information that he gave me which helped
me become a Multi multi millionaire now
for you right now I'm gonna do a very
very special offer because you're
watching this and maybe you've seen this
because you saw a little Lord Sugar
stuff and maybe the Lord Sugar bought
you here but if you're watching this
because you saw the Lord Sugar stuff you
can actually there's a discount code
there's a coupon code if you put sugar
in the discount code you'll get it for
free okay so below in the description in
the link there's a little link you can
click on it that it will say four
thousand eight two-pound but that will
drop to zero when you put sugar in the
coupon code and you can get all the same
advice that he gave me for free thank
you so much for watching this video guys
smash the like button and looked into
your comments and thoughts in the
comments box below and don't forget to
subscribe
turn on the notification bow so you
never miss a video more videos coming
soon peace out
[Music]